pour les avocats la lutte contre la
réforme des retraites continue en
courant ou à vélo
deux membres du barreau montpelliérains
sont à l'origine d'une course doléances
une nouvelle offensive contre le projet
de réforme des retraites qui vise à
supprimer la caisse autonome des avocats
vous voyez l'inventivité la créativité
le moyen de montrer que toute une
profession peut se mobiliser dans
l'unité dans la solidarité dans la
confraternité manière ludique de manière
artistique dans toutes les formes de
mobilisation
durant ce périple de baroan barreaux les
bâtonnets ont rempli des cahiers de
doléances ambulants pour faire part de
leurs revendications
si au départ elle ne concernait que les
retraites
les requêtes se sont étendues des
magistrats qui écroulent tous les
dossiers des délais du ciss qui explose
non pas en raison de la grève des
avocats mais uniquement en raison du
manque de moyens matériels humains en
juridiction
qu'est-ce qu'on retrouve à des choses
simples des logiciels qui
dysfonctionnent des greffiers qui n'ont
plus de bic
à partir du mois de septembre qui n'ont
plus de ramettes de papier qui doivent
acheter sur leurs deniers personnels des
dés de lancre pour leurs imprimantes etc
voilà ce qu'on retrouve c'est à dire une
justice à l'état de délabrement justice
que l'on qualifie de moyenâgeuse
mais leur voyage fut bien plus long de
1200 kilomètres parcourus quarante
quatre étapes au départ de la roche sur
yon bordeaux ou encore saint nazaire le
dernier coup de s'est déroulée à
versailles avant de rejoindre les hauts
de seine et le coeur de la capitale
la justice dans la théorie de la
séparation des pouvoirs de montesquieu
de l' équilibre des pouvoirs
ben c'est le troisième pouvoir qui fait
que les deux autres se sont aussi un peu
près tenu en équilibre et on voit bien
que c'est pas le cas du tout et que du
coup cette heure cette misère de la
justice
elle laisse toute la place a atteint à
la fois de l'erreur de l'aléa mais aussi
de pouvoir manipuler la justice à des
fins à des fins politiques
ce mercredi les cahiers ont atteint la
ligne d'arrivée le ministère de la
justice à l'attention particulière de
nicole belloubet la garde des sceaux
n'étant pas là c'est son directeur de
cabinet qui a reçu les dossiers
les avocats toujours en grève espèrent
pour la suite de bonnes nouvelles